right hand fools do make some free
throws I'm 37 to 31 Orlando folks inside
that's up Bob but marquel full George
three assists in is 11 minutes go full
speed to the lane and fires and it falls
rebound tapped to Tim Frazier by Bob
Baker
[Applause]
the lane Markel both jams we can make
great hired driving is old marçal Falls
but then this is the strength of folks
this is what he does best right
Markel folks against DeAndre hunter
follow a jumper a beauty by folks his
first field goal of the game are open
marquel Fultz is one of those guys that
has the ability to collapse the defense
get inside create space for himself a
great lizard belly has not made an
effort hadn't even attempted one in a
regular season but he had been Simonton
something in common with his ball
handling ability last year here's
another good defensive play by courts
relevant freeze your juniors
good-looking 3-point shot by Melvin
Frazier Junior
[Applause]
Volk says picked up by Fernando drives
past him and leaves it in charge all
right five Fernando terrific job Kanter
come back his way in good play by Cole
yeah one both scoops a pass going on -
no good shot
waiters on the attack that takes it away
Amina's and a blocking foul scored the
basket for al-farouq Aminu but now watch
mark hill folks move his feet excellent
job there over the top to Jones he lost
it it has picked up my faults and CW
right there on the help may have got a
piece of that one what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content